[موسيقى]
طريق ينثر على اطراف الفاعلون في الملف
السوري نقاطهم الامنيه المتقاربه فمعادله
الامن هنا دقيقه ومعقده هذه مناطق محاذيه
لتركيا تسيطر عليها قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه قوات كرديه تتهمها انقر
بتهديد امنها وبربط علاقات مع حزب العمال
كردستانيه لذا ترفض اقترابها من الحدود
وتراقب تحركاتها جوا كما تضربها بين الحين
والاخر
وتهددها بعمل بري كبير
التهديدات التركيه بشان عمليه عسكريه في
شمال شرق سوريا متواصله الهدف المعلن
اقامه منطقه امنه بعمق 30 كيلومتر ولتحقيق
هذا المسعى تخطط القوات التركيه والفصائل
المواليه لها الدخول الى منبج والى كوباني
المجاوره وصرت
ما يعني عمليا شريطا حدوديا خاضعا لتركيا
من ادلب الى حدود قامشلي
شريط يقطع اوصال منطقه كرديه ممتده في
المنطقه تعيد اليه تركيا اللاجئين
السوريين
تحاول ربط مناطق التي تحتلها في منطقه
الابيض
وجرابلس كل هذه الامور انا ما نجمعها
بدا حمله عسكريه هناك لكن ليس مرتبطه
ايضا نحن ناخذ هذه التهديدات بشكل جدي
ونتعامل معها بشكل جدي
[موسيقى]
خطه تجعل قصد بحاجه الى هذه النقاط التي
نمر على مقربه منها
سيناريوهات المعركه في منبج وكوباني
وترفعت مختلفه تخضع لخارطه النفوذ فمثلا
حيث اقف الان خلفي موقع عسكري تابع للنظام
من المفترض ان يكون هذا الموقع بالاضافه
الى مواقع اخرى تابعا لنظام خط المواجهه
الاول مع القوات التركيه والفصائل
المواليه لانقره في حال قررت التقدم ودخول
منبج لكن حسابات السياسه وتجارب السابقه
قد تفرض واقعا مختلفا في حال قرر دمشق
اتخاذ موقف الحياد
موقف حياد لا تتمناه قصد لكنها ترى بعض
مؤشراته حتى الان مواقف خجوله وتحركاتهم
ايضا خجوله وتحضيراتهم ايضا خجوله لكن
لديهم تواجد ونحن نامل يكونوا يشاركوا
معنا في المعركه ان حصلت هل هناك
اتفاق برعايه روسيه الانتشار حرس الحدود
التابعه لقوات حكومه دمشق هذه القوات
الموجوده حتى الان في الاونه الاخيره ليس
قبل الاشهر كان هناك زياده عدد القوات وهم
متواجدون فبالتاكيد نحن كقوات نؤكد ان
القوات المتواجده على خطوط التماسك مع
الجانب التركي هي قوات حرس الحدود التابعه
النظام مع
تدابير لنا
سياسيا ايضا يرصد الاكراد انعطافه في
علاقه دمشق وانقره تثير مخاوفهم اي
التقارب بين الطرفين سيكون على حساب
الاداره الذاتيه وعلى اساءاع على حساب
الشعب السوري وعلى حساب قوات سوريا الديمق
هذا يعني في نقاط هذا هذه النقاط المشتركه
بين
هذين النظامين
اكيد كان هناك اتفاقيه اضنه موجوده يعني
بين الطرفين سيكون تجديد لهذه الاتفاقيه
روسيا التي تراقب المشهد من نقاطها
الامنيه هنا تعمل على تخفيض اي توتر يقوض
سياده حليفها النظام اذ ترفض عملا عسكريا
للاطراك لكنها تعقد اتفاقيات لتسيير
دوريات مشتركه معهم كل هذا فيما تعزز
وجودها قرب الامريكيين المعنيين اولا
بالحرب على داعش صار بنعيشوبه العربيه من
شمال شرق سوريا